بارون واصل دائما في السياق ذات في فقره
وقف ما الحدث مشاهدينا الكرام مع خالد
الغرابي خالد اهلا بك وما مساء الخير
انباء ومعلومات متضاربه بشان هذا السقوط
المحتمل لصواريخ روسيه في بولندا ما
المعلومات المتوفره لديك
وفضلنا نبدا من اول ما ظهرت المعلومات
كانت من وكاله انباء امريكيه نقلت عن
مسؤول في الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان
صاروخين روسيين سقط في بولندا وادايا الى
وفاه عدد من الاشخاص ماذا يعني ذلك ما
الذي يمكن ان افهمه لازم معلومات انا
الامريكيين يعلمون ان الصواريخ التي سقطت
صواريخ روسيه وان الامريكيين يرفضون
الافصاح عن ذلك بشكل رسمي لانه بعد ذلك
خرج البنتاجون ليقول انه يتاكد يتحرى هذه
المعلومات انا هناك صواريخ سقطت وانها
صواريخ روسيه من المهم ان نعرف ذلك بولندا
المعنيه بالامر التي حدث على ارضها هذا
التفجير همم لم تتهم روسيا بشكل مباشر
وانما عقدت اجتماع المجلس الامن القومي
المجر عقد اجتماع المجلس الامن القومي
وتريد ان تعرف ما الذي يحدث بالضبط طبعا
ااكرانيا زيسكي خرج ليتهم روسيا ليس فقط
يتهم روسيا بشكل مباشر بل يقول هذه صفعه
وجهت للمجتمعين في قمه العشرين وعلى حلف
الاطلسي ان يفعل الماده الخامسه وان يكون
له رد على روس يعني مواجهه عسكريه مع
روسيا طبعا روسيا خرجت
لتقول انها همم هذه ادعاءات بانها لم تقصف
حتى المناطق الحدوديه مع بولندا والصواريخ
التي همم قيل انها سقطت ليس لها ليس لها
اي علاقه
بمنظومات الاسلحه الروسيه وانها لم تقصف
هذه المنطقه هذه الاتهامات في حد ذاتها هي
همم استفزازات وبالتالي هذه مجمل ال- ال-
المواقف التي تتطور بين لحظه اخرى وهل تمت
ما يدعم اتهامات زيلين المباشره لروسيا
اوكرانيا لم تكشف عن اي معطيات اا موثقه
تثبت ان ما سقط على الاراضي البولنديه هو
هي صواريخ روسيه همم
ربما يكون لديها لكنها على في النهايه لم
تنشر همم الاسئله التي تطرح حاليا حكيم في
العديد من الدول الغربيه الاتيه اولا همم
هل الصاروخ هل مصدر هذه التفجيرات صواريخ
روسيه ام لا البعض يعتقد انها صواريخ
الروسيه واربما بولندا عندما تعلن وضع بعض
القوات في حالهم وتقول انها تريد تفعيل
الماده الرابعه هي هي الماده الرابعه هي
للتشاور هي حاليا تقوم بالتشاور لا تحتاج
الى تفعيل الماده الرابعه لكن كلمه تفعيل
الماده الرابعه يعني وضع حلف الاطلس بشكل
رسمي في الموضوع وتسليم الملف يتعامل مع
روسيا لكن الحلف الاطلسي هو الولايات
المتحده ولن يحدث شيء في حلف الاطلسي بدون
موافقه الولايات المتحده التي ما زالت حره
الموضوع اذا هناك جزء من الدول ومنها
بولندا على ما يبدو تسير باتجاه ان هذا
الصاروخ صاروخ روسي مع العلم ان دول اخرى
تريد ان تتاكد طيب اذا كان الصاروخ روسي
هل هو خطا ام رساله ارسلت من همم موسكو
لننظر الى هذه الخارطه التي هي خلفي روسيا
قامت احتمال الخطا وارد لان روسيا قامت
بكميه كبيره من الهجمات الصاروخيه
والسهدفت غرب اوكرانيا تحديدا الفيف هذه
المنطقه القريبه من الخط الحدودي والقريبه
من القريه التي وقع فيها الانفجار البعض
يقول من الممكن ان يكون هناك خطا لكن
حقيقه يصعب تخيل ان صاروخ كان يتجه الى
هذا المنطقه وصل الى هذه المنطقه عن طريق
الخطا صواريخ الروسيه صواريخ محمله باجهزه
جي بي اس بمنظومه gps ليتم توجيها بدقه ان
اخطاء الهدف بعده امطار لكن ليس في
الامطار لتصل الى هذه المنطقه التي تبعد
ما بين 80 الى 100 كلم اذا
الخطا يصعب تصوره لكن يبقى وارد لانه في
هذا الحرب راينا اخطاء لم نكن طاقه يبقى
سؤال اخر طب اذا لم يكن خطا هل هو رساله
روسيه الى الحلف الاطلسي لكي اجيب على
السؤال لابد ان نسال ما هي طبيعه هذه
الرساله المحتمله ان يقول ان انا قادرون
على الوصول الى بولندا الجميع يعلم ان رسي
قادر على الوصول الى بولندا ان يقول انه
الروسي يريد ان يقول الحلف الاطلسي نحن
قادرون على مواجهتهم وان مستعدون لهذه
المواجهه لماذا منذ بدايه حرب بعده اشهر
بعد بدايه الحرب بدا روس يقولون نحن نواجه
حلف الاطلسي التسليح تسليح من حلف الاطلس
هناك متطوعون همم محسوبين على انهم من دول
اعضاء حلف الاطلسي المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه تاتي من حرف الاطلسيه صور
الاقمار الصناعيه تاتي من حرف الاطلسي
الروس يقولون نحن نحارب حلف الاطلس على
الارض ومع ذلك لم يستهدفه دوله من دول
اعضاء حلف الاطلسي لانهم لا يريدون في
مواجهه مباشره
التي تغير اليوم ليدخل حلف الاطلس في
الحرب ستكون همم سيئه جدا لهم هم اصلا
بالاساس يواجهون صعوبه كبيره في مواجهه
القوات الاوكرانيه فما بالك لو دخل حالف
الاطلسي بالنسبه لي لا يوجد منطق على
الاطلاق في ان يكون روسيا يسعون الى مواجه
عسكريه مع حلف الاطلسي وان كان هذه
الصواريخ كانت روسيه ربما تكون عن طريق
الخطا ومن هنا الولايات المتحده العنصر
الوحيد الفعال والاساسي فحل بالاطلسي يعلم
ربما الكثير
ويبحث الموضوع ويريد ان يتاكد ان كان هي
فعلا روسيه خطا من روسيا يمكن الخطا يمكن
تدركه لكن لو كانت هناك رساله واضح التريث
الامريكي هي عدم رغبه في مواجهه ايضا بين
حلف الاطلسي وروسيا وسيتكشف الايام ساعات
المقبله ايضا حتى في تصريحات الرئيس شكرا